هذه الخراف ليست في طريقها الى الذبح انها
تتجه الى ساحه سباق فريد من نوعه في
نيوزيلندا سباق له شعبيه كبيره في البلاد
وعاده توارثتها الاجيال منذ زمن انها
مسابقه جيسي الصوف
هذه المنطقه ماستر تون الزراعيه وهنا تقام
بطوله جولدن شيرز الدوليه
افضل المشاركين من جميع انحاء العالم
في البدايه تدخل هذه الخراف دون اي فكره
عما ينتظرها او يحدث لها
المتسابقون يقومون بالامساك بها للبدء في
دخول اجواء المسابقه وهنا تجدر الاشاره
الى ان المشاركه ليست بالامر السهل اذ
تتطلب التمتع ببنيه جسديه قويه اضافه الى
الذكاء والسرعه البديهه من اجل تفادي
ركنات بعض الخراف الهائجه اثناء جزيره
فيها
[موسيقى]
تبدا عمليه تجسس في هذا الخروف الصغير
واخذ كامل الصوفي المتشابك وفرشه على
الطاوله ثم يتم تجذيبه بمهاره مع قص
الاجزاء غير المرغوب بها وبعد اقل من 60
ثانيه تبدا عمليه جزي خروف
وكل ذلك لابد ان يتم بسرعه عاليه وحرفيه
ودقه فجاز الصوفي هنا في نيوزيلندا يعتبر
رياضه لها ابطالها لدرجه ان لها اتحادا
رياضيا خاصا جوين هنري هو احد ابرز ابطال
جنس في الخراف في نيوزيلندا حقق هذا الرجل
القهبا عده في هذا النوع من المسابقات
في بلد يبلغ عدد سكانه نحو خمسه ملايين
نسمه فقط
من الدول الاساسيه المصدره للصوف في
العالم ولديها ما يقرب من 25 مليون راس من
الخريف بعد ان كانت تملك نحو 72 مليون راس
في ثمانينات القرن الماضي وبالرغم من هذا
الانخفاض الا ان مبيعاتها بلغت نحو 284
مليون دولار في مختلف انحاء العالم في
العام الماضي
تجسد الصوف حرفه تورثتها الاجيال في مزارع
انخرافر نيوزلنديه فبعض المتسابقين هنا
وصل اجدادهم الى المرحله النهائيه في
مسابقه جولدن شيرز ليجاز الصوف وذلك في
الستينيات القرن الماضي
[ضحك]
في كل عامة يتوافد المتسابقون من جميع
انحاء العالم الى هذا المكان
للمشاركه في هذا الحدث الفريد الذي تستمر
فعالياته لثلاثه ايام وتتضمن مسابقات لقص
ومناوله وكيلسوف
[موسيقى]